والمزيد معنا من القاهره ريم ندى المتحدثه
باسم برنامج الغذاء العالمي اهلا بك ريم
بدايه هل وصلتم الى تقرير شامل ربما
يعطيكم فكره عن وضع الماساه على الارض او
لا زلتم في مرحله التقييم
هي الماساه واضحه طبعا لكل الاشخاص
العاملين في الاغاثه وايضا حتى للناس
الذين يتفرجون على التلفزيون حاليا حتى
عمال الاغاثه انفسهم حتى موظفين برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه المتواجدين في غازي
عنتاب لانه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي له
تواجد في غازي عنتاب كما له تواجد في كل
انحاء سوريا وايضا
يوصل المساعدات الى شمال شرق
شمال الشمال الغربي ايضا خاصه في منطقه
ادلب ولكن يعني التقييم الاولي لبرنامج
الاغذيه العالميه انا هناك
نصف مليون شخص برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
يهدف الوصول الى النصف مليون شخص لتقديم
المساعدات على مدار ثلاثه والاربع اشهر
القادمه حتى الان امس فقط تم توزيع
مساعدات غذائيه من وجبات ساخنه
حصص غذائيه جاهزه للاكله لانه الاشخاص ليس
لديهم
وين ريم وين استطعت الوصول اين استطعت
الوصول
في حالات تم توزيع وجبات ساخنه للمتضررين
من الموجه الزلازل وايضا تم توزيع في
اللاذقيه وتم توزيع الان يتم ايصال
مساعدات غذائيه في تركيا
في
جنوب تركيا الى
المخيم مخيمات اللاجئين الموجوده التي بها
ايضا مواطنين اتراك هناك
17000 حصه غذائيه الان ويهدف البرنامج الى
الوصول الى 300 الف شخص
بالمساعده في تركيا بالمساعدات الغذائيه
وتوفير الوجبات الساخنه في الفتره القادمه
لما عم نحكي وجبات ساخنه بس عشان افهم
فكره الحصص اللي انتم بتبعتوها هي يوميه
بمعنى اخر ليوم واحد او انه لعده ايام
ممكن تكفيهم الحصص الغذائيه تكفي لمده
سبعه ايام هي لا تحتاج الى الى طهي ولا
تحتاج الى وقود ولا تحتاج الى كل هذه
الاشياء لانه يعلم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه انا في ظل هذه الظروف هذه
يعني هذه ظروف غير متوفره للعائلات الذين
هم يعني حتى الذين يعيشون في
مناطق الاستضافه للاجئين في تركيا الان
يستضيف هذه
المناطق تستضيف مواطنين اتراك ايضا
فحجم التحديات وطبيعتها باختصار ريم
بالنسبه لالكم طبعا
الطرقات هي صعبه ولكن الان هناك شاحنات
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه هي المتجهه الى
مخيم العثمانيه لسبعه عشر الف شخص بصوره
مبدئيه ولكن سيتم التوزيع تباعا اما ايضا
هناك
بالتعاون مع شركاء البرنامج في الجنوب
التركي الذي ايضا كان له برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في وقت
جاء احد الكوفيد 19 تم تم تفعيل
الوجبات الساخنه من خلال الشركاء وهذا ما
يسعى برنامج الاغذيه العالميه الى تفعيله
وايضا يساعد تسعه محافظات في سوريا طبعا
كلها في عفوا في تركيا كلها في الجنوب
التركي
لمساعده هذه المحافظه
على التوسع في
تقديم الوجبات الساخنه الى المتضررين من
الزلزال الاشخاص الذين فقدوا منازلهم
الاشخاص الذين تجردوا بسبب الازمه الحصص
الغذائيه موجوده ومتوفره او بانتظار
ايصالها ومن خلال المعابر اذا ما تحدثنا
عن سوريا او من خلال المطارات باختصار ريم
معبر باب الهوى الذي يتم من خلاله ايصال
المساعدات الغذائيه عبر الحدود التركيه هو
يعمل ولكن في بطء لانه هناك طبعا
مشكلات بسبب الزلزال ولكن هو يعمل
الان يبحث البرنامج ايضا عن كل الطرق
البديله لايصال المساعد وسنتابع معكم طبعا
التطورات من القاهره ريم ندى المتحدثه
باسم برنامج الغذاء العالمي شكرا جزيلا